-Now, usually when we start
"A Closer Look,"
we tell you at the top
which news stories
we're about to cover.
Obviously, we have a bit more
than usual to catch up on today,
so just bear with me
while I try to get through this.
Donald Trump appeared
in a Manhattan courthouse today
for a fraud trial after a judge
ruled that he and his family
had lied about their
business assets for years.
House Republicans
descend into chaos
and finger-pointing after nearly
shutting down the government
while simultaneously
embarrassing themselves
with the sham
impeachment inquiry
into Joe Biden
that even their own witnesses
admitted did not have
any evidence.
Florida Congressman
Matt Gaetz announced
that he'll try to remove
Kevin McCarthy
as Speaker of the House.
Trump is preparing
for another hearing
over a proposed gag order
to stop him
from making threats in the run
up to a criminal trial.
Attempted coup trial dates
have been set
in three of Trump's
criminal cases
for stealing
classified documents,
trying to overturn the election,
and paying hush money
to a porn star.
Trump was caught on tape
admitting
that he had
secret military documents
that were not declassified,
kept boxes of classified
documents in his bathroom.
He was found liable
for sexual abuse
in a civil trial,
called the former chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
to be executed,
reneged on a promise
to pay his ex-lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani,
who was also indicted
by a grand jury in Atlanta
for election interference
and is being sued by his
ex-lawyer for failure to pay,
as well as by Hunter Biden
for tampering with his laptop.
Trump was overheard saying
the words "hang" on January 6th
as a riotous mob tried
to hang his vice president.
Rudy was drunk
during the insurrection.
Trump Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows
burned so many documents
in his fireplace
that his suit smelled
like a Boy Scout jamboree.
Ted Cruz said Barbie
is indoctrinating children
with Chinese propaganda.
The Atlantic grand jury
recommended an indictment
of Lindsey Graham,
among many
other Trump allies.
Trump's former doctor
turned Congressman Ronny Jackson
got detained at a rodeo.
Trump said windmills
are killing whales
and that dampening forest fires
with water would stop fires.
Chris Christie called him
Donald Duck.
Marjorie Taylor Greene
showed off a giant poster board
with Hunter Biden
nudes in Congress
and confused Yom Kippur
with Hanukkah.
Congressman George Santos
and Senator Bob Menendez
both indicted.
Mike Lindell
got mad in a lawsuit
because someone called
his pillows lumpy,
and Lauren Boebert got to second
base at a "Beetlejuice" musical.
Did...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did I miss anything?
Oh, right.
Trump went to a gun store
and held a Glock like he was
a "Price Is Right" model.
[ Laughter ]
For more on much of that
as we can get to,
it's time for
"A Closer Look to the Max!"
-To the max.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Donald Trump arrived
in New York last night
to stay at his possibly
soon-to-be-renamed residence,
Trump Tower,
ahead of his appearance today
at a Manhattan courthouse
for fraud trial.
And I just want to say
it's really nice of him
to come back to New York
for our first show.
He heard the strike
was over and said,
[Imitating Trump]
"I can't miss 'A Closer Look.'"
[ Normal voice ]
In fact, this is very exciting.
He's in the audience
with us right now.
So, if you're in the studio
and you hear a beeping sound,
don't worry.
That's just his court-ordered
ankle bracelet going off.
I'm just kidding.
Trump's not here.
He's home recuperating
after a long day of scowling.
Here he is arriving
at the courthouse
for the fraud trial today
and standing there
waiting to go in
like a guy waiting to use
the bathroom at a concert.
[Imitating Trump]
"Come on, hurry up.
I want to get back to my seats
before he plays 'Piano Man.'
Where is he now?
Davy Crockett, Peter Pan,
Elvis Presley, Disneyland.
Alright, I got time."
[ Normal voice ] And then,
of course, he could not
restrain himself from launching
into an unhinged tirade
for the assembled press
where he, among other things,
attacked the attorney general
who brought the case
and the judge overseeing it.
I don't want to amplify
most of what he said,
but here's a quick time-lapse,
just to give you an idea
of what fraud defendant
Donald Trump was doing
as he waited
to enter the courtroom.
-This is a continuation
of the single greatest
witch hunt of all time.
She said, "Well, now I'll go
back to get Trump again,"
and this is what we have.
It's a scam. It's a sham.
People are being murdered all
over the sidewalks of New York.
If I didn't run, I'd be sitting
right now at a beach
like Biden does every time,
even though he's supposed
to be working.
They have one property
that's worth
anywhere from 50 to 100 times
what this judge put down
as their value -- Coca-Cola.
Take a look at their value.
They have a value.
The value of their brand
is more than everything else
put together.
One other thing.
We have a clause in the contract
which tells, essentially,
"Buyer beware."
When you take a look
at the financial statement,
don't believe anything you read.
Do not believe anything.
If I weren't running,
I wouldn't have
any of these cases.
I wouldn't be seeing you
this morning,
but I'll be seeing
a lot of you.
-"I'll be seeing a lot of you"?
He sounds like a creepy husband
from a Lifetime movie.
[Imitating Trump] "I'll be
seeing a lot of you, Deborah.
You'll never find
all the cameras I installed."
[ Normal voice ]
By the way, that was time-lapse.
That was three days.
He started Friday during the
rainstorm and hasn't stopped.
At one point, the water
was up to his waist,
and he still kept going.
Also, generally speaking,
I would say it's not exactly
a genius legal strategy
to attack the judge right before
you walk into his courtroom.
"This guy's an ass [bleep]
a loser.
I hate his guts, and I hope
he rules in my favor."
[ Laughter, applause ]
Most of that rant was
the standard Trump word vomit,
but I do want to touch on a few
quick things like this.
-The reason I got indicted
was that I ran.
If I didn't run, I'd be sitting
right now at a beach
like Biden does every time,
even though he's supposed
to be working.
-Yeah, I just can't imagine
Donald Trump sitting on a beach.
A beach implies relaxation.
If Trump ever did go to a beach,
he'd spend the entire time
arguing with the seagulls.
[Imitating Trump]
"Excuse me, Mr. Seagull.
Mr. Sea-- Those are my chips.
Excuse me. I'm talking.
Squawk, squawk, squawk,
squawk to you.
Excuse me."
[ Normal voice ] But arguably,
the most bizarre thing
he said during his rant
was when he claimed
he couldn't be held liable
for any of the false statements
about his business assets
because his financial documents
have a disclaimer in them
that says nothing
in them is true.
-We have a clause
in the contract
which tells, essentially,
"Buyer beware."
We have a clause
in the contract.
It's like
a "buyer beware" clause.
It says when you take a look
at the financial statement,
don't believe anything you read.
This is up front.
Don't believe anything you read.
Some people call it
a worthless clause
because it makes the statement
and anything you read
in the statement worthless.
It says go out
and do your own research.
Go out and do your own
due diligence.
You have to study
the statement carefully.
Do not believe anything.
-Wait, what?
You can't be held liable
because your business records
have a disclaimer that says,
"Don't believe any of this"?
He's talking about
his bank records
like it's the warning
before an episode of "Jackass."
[ Laughter ]
Do his tax returns also say,
"Don't try this at home"?
So, then after he spent
a few minutes
further incriminating himself,
Trump entered the courtroom
where he sat down
at the defense table.
And as you can see from these
images, he's having a blast.
Generally speaking,
if you're an alleged criminal
trying to look innocent
at a fraud trial,
I would not go
with menacing scowl.
If you didn't know the context
and just saw his face,
you'd think he was on trial
for all the murders.
That's his audition tape
to play a Klingon general.
[ Laughter ]
But I have to say,
the scene that I found
especially incredible
was this shot of
Attorney General Letitia James
perfectly positioned
in the background,
over Trump's shoulder,
staring at --
look at that shot!
What cinematography!
Did they get the same director
who did "Succession"?
[ Laughter ]
The only thing --
[ Applause ]
Wonderful.
The only thing missing
from this scene was Cousin Greg.
What's Trump saying
in the courtroom, Greg?
"Uh, I think he's, uh,
suggesting that, uh, perhaps
in terms of the, uh,
jurisprudence
of -- of the, uh, uh, legal
proceedings,
that he's, um, uh, completely
[bleep]"
Now, in a way,
Trump has already lost this case
before he stepped foot
in the courtroom
because last week,
before the trial even began,
the judge found Trump
had lied about
his business assets for years.
And now, the attorney general
is asking the judge
to bar him from doing business
in New York,
which means Trump
could lose everything.
-We begin with a major ruling
in a civil case
against Donald Trump
and his family business.
In a 35-page decision yesterday,
Manhattan judge Arthur Engoron
found the former president
and his two oldest sons
and their companies
liable for fraud.
The judge found Trump
"repeatedly submitted
fraudulent financial documents
about the value
of his assets to banks
and other insurance companies,"
and that his financial
statements were
"based in a fantasy world,
not the real world."
The attorney general's team
sought to convince the judge
in this case that Trump should
be barred from doing business
in the state of New York.
-The former president
could eventually lose control
of iconic properties
like Trump Tower.
-Is it clear?
Does he have $250 million?
If that was an actual penalty
that the company was to pay?
-I'm not sure how liquid
he is at the moment
and whether he could pay that,
but this is obviously
a big question
is what his actual assets are.
-That's right -- Trump might
not even have the money
to pay the penalty
in his fraud trial,
which means there's a remote
but realistic possibility
that Trump Tower
gets taken away,
he has to sell Mar-a-Lago,
and he ends up crashing
with Rudy Giuliani.
[Imitating Trump]
"I call top bunk."
[Imitating Giuliani] "But,
Boss, I don't have a bunk bed."
[Imitating Trump] "You can sleep
under the mattress."
[Imitating Giuliani]
"Oh, this is great.
Maybe this will finally
straighten out my neck.
My chiropractor says
I have a condition
called Gargoyle Spine."
[ Laughter ]
So, the actual trial
began today.
Trump and his lopsided adult
sons are on the witness list,
but the judge in the case
has already effectively ruled
that the facts
are not in dispute.
He wrote in his ruling
that Trump's inflated claims
about his business assets
constitute obvious fraud.
-The judge effectively decided
he didn't need a trial
to determine
the Trumps were liable.
The judge wrote
in his ruling,
"This is a fantasy world,
not the real world,"
and admonished
the former president
for his overvaluing his holdings
by as much as $2.2 billion.
In one example,
Trump overestimated
the size
of his Manhattan apartment,
which he spent years living in,
by 19,000 feet, or 200%.
Judge Engoron called that
absurd, writing,
"a discrepancy of this order
of magnitude
by a real estate developer
sizing up his own living space
of decades
can only be considered fraud."
-Trump inflated
his own apartment size by 200%.
In other words,
he tripled it.
I wouldn't be surprised
if the photos were fake, too.
Remember how we all thought
it looked like this?
That's photoshopped.
If you remove the filter,
it looks like this.
[ Laughter ]
This ruling undercuts
his entire mythology.
Everything about him is a lie.
Not only were his businesses
and net worth inflated,
but he even pretended
his own apartment
was three times bigger
than it actually was.
Next, we're going to find out
he and Melania are just friends.
I'm kidding.
Friends like each other.
And yet, somehow, this fraud
trial could very well --
very well be the least
of Trump's concerns.
As we all know,
he's got four upcoming
criminal cases to deal with,
and trial dates have been set
for three of those cases.
We'll tell you all about that,
right after this break.
Wait. We're allowed
to do a commercial
during "A Closer Look?"
Is that a new thing?
Alright.
Let's see how it goes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, as I was saying...
...before I was
so rudely interrupted
by our incredibly
valuable advertisers --
thank you so much.
On top of the civil fraud trial
Trump appeared at today
in Manhattan,
he's also, of course,
facing four indictments --
three more, it should be noted,
than the Unabomber,
who, as the "Una" implies,
had just the one.
One of Trump's indictments,
of course, involves
the classified documents
he stole from the White House,
and at the House GOP
sham impeachment hearing
into Joe Biden last week,
Congresswoman Jasmine Crockett
compared the stolen documents,
some of which were found
in Trump's bathroom,
to the allegations
against Biden
with an especially memorable
choice of words.
-As I walked
into this chamber today,
as I prepared, I said,
"What is the crime?"
Because when you're talking
about impeachment,
you're talking about
high crimes or misdemeanors.
And I can't seem
to find the crime.
And honestly, no one
has testified of what crime
they believe the President of
the United States has committed.
But when we start talking about
things that look like evidence,
they want to act
like they blind.
They don't know what this is.
These are our national secrets,
looks like in the [bleep] to me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yep.
Much like the country
when he was in office,
Trump left his classified
documents in the [bleep]
And I really appreciate
that choice of words
because it accurately captures
the decor of Trump's bathroom.
It doesn't look like
a powder room or a lavatory.
It looks like a [bleep]
fancy [bleep]
but it's a [bleep] nonetheless.
I mean, put aside the fact
that there are boxes
of stolen classified documents
in there, you know,
just in case you run out of
Golf Digests
or "Family Circuses."
He's got a fancy chandelier
right next
to a cheap curtain rod.
I don't think I've ever seen
a weirder combination
of expensive and chintzy choices
in a bathroom before.
It's like a porta-potty
with monogrammed towels.
[ Laughter ]
If you're going to lay out
for the chandelier,
why not just get
a proper shower installed
or a sliding glass door
or something?
This looks like the bathroom
at a funeral home in Yonkers.
And by the way,
you know Trump calls it
the [bleep] too.
Like, when he's on his private
jet with his gang of weirdos
complaining about the bathroom
being occupied.
[Imitating Trump]
"Where's Rudy?"
[ Normal voice ]
"He's still in the [bleep] sir.
Sometimes he breathes
in too much hair dye
and passes out in there."
[Imitating Giuliani]
"Boss! It happened again.
I had the craziest dream where
I was the president's lawyer.
I am?!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
And while we're on the subject,
you might be wondering
how Republicans
could have possibly
defended this.
Here's soon-to-be-former
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
offering a defense of Trump's
bathroom/filing cabinet
back in June.
Yeah, bathroom...
[ Laughter ]
Bathroom doors lock
so you can pee in private,
not so you can use it
as a home safe.
Also, the bathroom door
kind of famously
has the flimsiest lock
in the house.
If you're watching
a horror movie
and a character runs into
the bathroom and locks the door,
say your goodbyes.
There isn't a single normal
human being
who keeps important
things in the bathroom.
"Hey, honey, where's
our marriage certificate?"
"It's next to the plunger."
Also, a bathroom door
only locks from the inside.
If no one's in there,
it's open.
So, what you're saying is
our nation's most sensitive
and highly guarded secrets
are safe,
as long as someone's
in there taking a dump.
Do we assign someone from the
archives department to that job,
or is that more
of a Secret Service thing?
"Agent Callahan, your bathroom
shift starts at 5:00 a.m.
Better start pounding
some bran."
[ Laughter, applause ]
So, the faraway frontrunner
for the GOP nomination
is facing four indictments
and a civil fraud case
that could end
his entire business.
But fair is fair.
And I do want to give
the Republican Party credit.
I'm happy to report that
in the five months
since we were last on the air,
the GOP has undergone
a radical transformation
into a serious,
sober-minded collection
of diligent professionals
capable of
competently administering
the basic functions
of government.
And I'm just kidding.
It's still a giant
ass-over-teakettle
cluster [bleep]
-This is CNN Breaking News.
-Good evening, everyone.
This is CNN special live
coverage on a chaotic night,
even by Washington standards.
I'm Dana Bash,
live in the nation's capital.
Here's the headline.
The United States government
will not shut down,
at least not
for another 45 days.
-The House Speaker had his back
up against the wall, it seems.
He was not going to get anywhere
with his Republican
conference alone.
There was just
too much infighting
going on inside the conference.
And so, he had to work with
Democrats to get this done here.
-This all comes, Jake,
as the tension was palpable
among some of the Republicans.
-The fate of House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy
is uncertain at this time
as hardliners in his party
are pushing for his ouster.
-Do you still support him,
Mr. Speaker?
-I had my questions.
I have my doubts.
-We cannot blame the Democrats
for having not done our job.
-This is a huge mess.
-I've been frustrated
by the process.
I thought we would be
better than this.
-"Yeah, we're Republicans.
We're supposed to be
better than this.
We're the party of serious
statesmen like Rudy Giuliani,
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Mike Lindell,
and the lady who got horned up
at the 'Beetlejuice' musical."
Seriously, Republicans,
why did you think
you would be better than this?
Did you forget
the entire Trump presidency?
And if so, can you send me
some of the pills
that helped you do that?
You're like a Jets fan saying,
"I think this is our year,"
after Aaron Rodgers went down.
[ Applause ]
So, Republicans
basically caused
a bunch of pointless chaos
and paralysis,
pushing us to the brink
of a shutdown
that would imperil millions of
Americans' paychecks and jobs.
And in the end, they had to be
bailed out by Democrats,
who supplied most of the votes
to keep the government open.
And now, because of that,
GOP hardliner Matt Gaetz,
McCarthy's chief antagonist
in the GOP caucus,
is threatening to stir up
even more chaos
by filing a motion
to remove McCarthy as Speaker.
-The future of Kevin McCarthy's
speakership is in peril
after he teamed up
with Democrats
to avert a government shutdown.
Well, this morning,
Congressman Matt Gaetz
says that he is moving forward
with a motion to vacate
to try to oust
McCarthy as Speaker.
-I do intend to file
a motion to vacate
against Speaker McCarthy
this week.
-He says he's coming for you.
Can you survive?
-Yes, I'll survive.
-Oof, that's the worst Gloria
Gaynor cover I've ever heard.
Gaetz vs. McCarthy is a real
"Alien vs. Predator" situation.
In fact, Gaetz and the alien
have the same size forehead,
so that's pretty cool.
So, the result,
keeping the government open,
must have been a relief
for millions of Americans,
including Joe Biden.
Although I will say
if the government had shut down,
I was kind of hoping Biden would
follow the late night host lead
and start a podcast
with the other living presidents
called "Air Force Five."
[ Laughter ]
[Imitating Biden] "Today's
episode is brought to you
by Manscape, the world leader
in male grooming."
[Imitating Obama]
"Oh, Manscape delivers
a peak performance...
for your most sensitive areas."
[Imitating Clinton]
"I feel your pain
when you use inferior grooming
tools."
[Imitating Carter]
"America..."
[ Laughter, applause ]
"America, I'm 99 years old,
and I still use
this product every day."
[Imitating Bush]
"Go to Manscape.com today.
Use promo code Bush."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"For 20% off...
your man bush."
[ Normal voice ]
Thank you.
Five...
Five months
in impression camp paid off.
We did one president
a month, obviously.
I've got a little rushed
on Carter month.
Republicans spent weeks
devouring each other
and self-immolating
to the point
that they couldn't be bothered
to keep the government open
until Democrats bailed them out.
And that's because
they were focused
on an even more
embarrassing spectacle --
an impeachment hearing
into Joe Biden,
where even Republicans admitted
they humiliated themselves.
We'll show you some of
the lowlights right after this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
As we told you before the break,
Republicans
could barely be bothered
to keep the government open
and had to turn to the Democrats
to bail them out.
Now, you might be
asking yourself
what could have
possibly been more important
than keeping
the government functioning?
What else was
the GOP focused on?
-The House GOP is focused
on Hunter Biden,
spending this entire Thursday
morning and afternoon,
again, just two days
before the government shuts down
on Saturday, to open
their impeachment inquiry
into his dad, the president.
They're looking into
Hunter Biden, as well.
-Even some Republicans this
morning are privately grumbling
about how that first
impeachment hearing went.
No bombshells,
no direct evidence
that President Biden
did anything wrong.
-I want to emphasize
what it is that
we're here today for.
This is a question
of an impeachment inquiry.
It is not a vote
on articles of impeachment.
In fact, I do not believe
that the current evidence
would support articles
of impeachment.
-That's your first witness?!
He just came out and [bleep]
all over your whole case.
That's like if the best man
at your wedding
got up to give a toast
and said,
"Hey, everybody,
keep your gift receipts.
This one ain't making it
through the summer."
[ Applause ]
And I'm not the only one
who was underwhelmed
by the witness choice.
Even pro-Trump hardliner
Steve Bannon
was critical
of the GOP's decision
to call as their first
impeachment witness
someone who doesn't think
there's enough evidence
for impeachment.
-That's maybe not a witness
I'd call initially
to lay out the case,
and if that was
the professor's thought
and that's what he believes,
maybe we sit around
a conference table
and say, "Hey,
when we have on the whiteboard
that professor's name,
why don't we put him
on the maybe category?
Why don't we -- maybe we bring
him in in a couple of weeks.
Maybe we don't start with him."
It's just an idea.
-Wow. You know it's bad
when even Steve Bannon
is sassing you for screwing up.
This is a guy who got [bleep]
canned after six months
in the White House,
got indicted twice,
got sentenced
to four months in prison
for contempt of Congress,
and can't decide
which collared shirt to wear,
so he just goes
with all of the above.
Fun fact -- to raise bail money,
he's been starring in that
"Beetlejuice" production
Lauren Boebert was at.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And by the way,
the GOP star witness
is not the only one to admit
they don't have any evidence.
A number of House Republicans
have already said
the same thing.
-I have not seen any evidence
that links President Biden
to Hunter Biden's activities
at this point.
-I actually wrote
down right here
some other
Republican congressmen
who have said similar things.
Dave Joyce, "Not seeing
any facts or evidence."
Don Bacon, "There should be
a direct link
to the president
in some evidence."
Dusty Johnson of South Dakota,
"I've not seen that evidence."
So, this is a widespread belief
among the House
Republican conference.
-We don't have the evidence now,
but we may find it later.
-They really said
we don't have it now,
but we may find it later.
He sounds like a Spirit employee
telling you they lost
your luggage.
"We don't have it right now,
but we may find it
at the bottom of
the Atlantic Ocean in 30 years.
Do you want us to call you?"
That should tell you
everything you need to know.
If they had any evidence
connecting Joe Biden
to improper
foreign business dealings,
they surely would
have presented it
in their first
impeachment hearing.
But they don't.
Why are they doing this?
Simple,
it's for political revenge
for the twice-impeached
Donald Trump.
And if you don't believe me,
just take it from Trump himself.
-They did it to me.
And had they not done it to me,
I think, and nobody
officially said this,
but I think had
they not done it to me --
and I'm very popular
in the -- you know,
they like me and I like them,
The Republican Party --
perhaps you wouldn't have it
being done to them.
And this is going to happen
with indictments, too.
-"Had they not done it to me,
you wouldn't have it
being done to them."
As usual, all you really
need to do is stick a microphone
in front of Trump's face,
and he'll confess.
He's the world's most notorious
pathological liar,
and yet he also just
blurts out the truth,
like he's on his way home
from the dentist.
"Mom, did you know
Dad has a friend named Kathy?
Because he says --
he says it's a secret."
[ Laughter ]
So, Republicans are running
interference for Trump
by pursuing pointless
political revenge against Biden.
But Trump, of course, is not the
only member of his inner circle
facing serious criminal
or financial penalties.
Trump's ex-lawyer
and codefendant Rudy Giuliani
was sued by his ex-lawyer,
and Mike Lindell melted down
in a deposition
over his election lies.
We'll show you that video
right after this.
As we've discussed
on this show many times,
the ironclad rule of Trumpism
is that devoting yourself
to this criminal weirdo
will always,
without fail,
end in humiliation.
And there is, of course,
no better example
of that than Rudy Giuliani,
seen here accidentally getting
his [bleep] caught in a zipper.
I'm just kidding.
The way Rudy wears his pants,
he's much more likely to get
his nipple caught in his zipper.
Rudy was in high demand at the
impeachment hearing last week,
where Democrats
kept demanding to know
why he hadn't been called
as a witness,
given that he was a key player
in Trump's scheme
to dig up dirt
on the Bidens.
-We must receive the testimony
of Rudy Giuliani and Lev Parnas,
the insiders who know
the origins of the lie
upon which this
sham impeachment is based
and who worked to spread it.
-I reclaim my time,
and I ask the question,
Where in the world
is Rudy Giuliani?
-"Where in the world
is Rudy Giuliani?"
sounds like a game show
where kids would have to guess
where Rudy was based on
where you told him to be.
"Alright, Gumshoes,
you tell Rudy Giuliani
to meet you
at the Best Western.
Where is he going to turn up?
At a screening of "Butch Cassidy
and the Sundance Kid"?
Correct.
He would think
that is the best Western.
Also, that piece of paper
that says, "Where is Rudy?"
looks like something
a limo driver
would hold up at the airport.
Rudy is, of course, a figure
in all of Trump's
various schemes
and spent a lot of money
helping him.
He flew around the country
on his own dime
and bought hair dye
by the barrel
just to try to sway
state lawmakers
to overturn the election
results for Trump.
And now, not only
has he been indicted for that,
he's also out of cash.
Things are reportedly so bad,
Rudy reportedly pleaded
with Trump to pay him.
And you'll never guess
how that turned out.
-Some exclusive new reporting
on the hundreds of thousands
of dollars in legal fees
that Rudy Giuliani
is now staring down
and the desperate attempts
that he has made
to get former President
Donald Trump to cover them.
With his attorney in tow,
I am told that Rudy Giuliani
traveled to Mar-a-Lago
in late April on a mission
to make a personal appeal
to Trump
to pay his legal bills.
But apparently,
it fell on deaf ears.
Trump is notoriously strict
about digging
into his own coffers.
He did not seem very interested,
I'm told,
in covering everything that
Giuliani and Costello wanted.
One source says that he
verbally agreed to help,
but he didn't commit to any
specific amount or timeline.
-I love that Trump shooed Rudy
away by saying he'd help
but wouldn't commit
to an amount or a timeline.
So, no.
The answer was no.
What was Trump's excuse?
[Imitating Trump]
"Sorry, Rudy, I can't even
afford a real shower rod
in my [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] And in a truly
wonderful turn of events,
Rudy is now, himself,
being sued by his own ex-lawyer
for failure
to pay his legal bills.
-Rudy Giuliani is being sued
by his former attorneys.
The law firm that represented
the former New York City mayor
says he owes them
more than $1.3 million
in unpaid legal fees.
-So, Donald Trump's ex-lawyer,
who has unpaid legal bills,
is being sued by his ex-lawyer
for unpaid legal bills,
which is a reminder only Trump
can pull off being Trump.
Trump's lawyer comes to him
asking for money he's owed,
Trump makes up some bull [bleep]
sends him away empty-handed,
and the lawyer is like,
"Oh, well, at least I tried."
Then that same lawyer
tries that same move
with his legal representation,
and they're like,
"[bleep] you, pay me."
[Imitating Giuliani]
"But what if I verbally agree
to pay you without a specific
amount or timeline?"
[ Normal voice ]
"[bleep] you, pay me."
[Imitating Giuliani]
"I swear,
this just worked on me
like a day ago."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] And Rudy is
not the only Trump crony
facing serious
financial consequences.
There's also
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell,
who is being sued for his own
part in spreading election lies.
And all of this is clearly
taking a toll on Lindell,
as evidenced by video
released from a deposition
in which he was grilled
about his election lies
and lost what was left
of his mind.
-Tell us your full name,
please.
-Michael James Lindell.
-Well, good morning,
Mr. Lindell.
-My name is Charlie Cain.
We met for the first time
about --
-Who's paying you?
-...about four minutes ago.
-Okay. Go.
-Is that right?
-What's that?
-Is what? What was the question?
-We met for the first time --
-Yes. Yes.
You're an ambulance-chasing
lawyer, so don't start with me.
I got all day.
I'll take as much time
as you want.
The question is, do people know
you as the MyPillow guy?
Blah, blah, blah.
I just gave my answer.
How dare him come
and sue MyPillow!
He's a scumbag for doing that.
Put that in there, scumbag.
S-C-U-M-bag.
-Does he not know
how to spell the word "bag"?
[ Laughter ]
I'd love to see him play
"Wheel of Fortune."
[Imitating Lindell] "Pat,
I'd like to buy an E, please.
[ Buzzer ]
[Imitating Sajak]
"I'm sorry. Your turn is up."
[Imitating Lindell]
"No, please, Pat, I need this.
Just give me the money.
I'm being sued
by a bunch of bad people
for saying weird things.
You don't even need
to let me win the game.
Just take the money
for the Hawaiian vacation
and put it in the bag.
Oh, wait.
That's the word, darn it.
It's not my turn.
Please, I need the cash.
Just let me skip ahead
and solve the puzzle.
Show me Hugo Chávez."
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
But the best part
of that deposition video
came when the lawyer alluded
to complaints
about Lindell's pillows using a
word that really set him off.
-I'm not asking about
the lumpy pillow calls.
-No, they're not
lumpy pillows.
That's not what they call on.
Okay?
When you say lumpy pillows,
now you're an ass [bleep]
You got that?
You're an ass [bleep]
is what you are.
-Mike.
-No, he's an ass [bleep]
He's an ambulance-chasing
ass [bleep]
That's what you are.
The lumpy pillows?
Kiss my ass.
Obviously, you don't have
a MyPillow, too.
You don't, do you?
-What I'm saying is,
Mr. Lindell --
-Ass [bleep]
-The phrase lumpy pillows
is such a funny thing
to fly off the handle over,
because even as an insult,
it's pretty tame.
It sounds like Minnesota
slang for testicles.
"Honey, I was watching
C-SPAN the other day
and Marjorie Taylor Greene
showed a picture
of Hunter Biden's
lumpy pillows."
[ Laughter ]
"Not to mention
his Paul Bunyan."
I will say Lindell
could probably generate
a lot more business if his ads
had that much bleeping.
-I personally [bleep] my [bleep]
be the most [bleep] [bleep]
you'll ever [bleep]
or your [bleep]
-This is the Republican Party,
and in the five months
we were off the air,
it hasn't changed.
Arguably, it's gotten worse.
It's a collection
of aspiring despots and weirdos
doing everything in their power
to insulate an alleged criminal
who instigated a coup
from accountability.
Donald Trump's place in the GOP
is kind of like a...
-Ass [bleep]
-In the [bleep]
[ Laughter, applause ]
-I still got it.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪